okay so getting into Marvel generations
the best this is a really really
interesting story and it's actually
pretty cool you know in terms of how it
unfolds remember for those of you guys
who are new here
Marvel generations is basically the
story that Marvel is using to segue into
the new branding new branding initiative
in the sense that with you know after
the events of Secret Wars 2015 you've
had all-new all-different marvel after
all-new all-different marvel you had
Marvel now 2.0 then you had secret
Empire secret Empire I would say is
probably part of Marvel now 2.0 but
because of the fact that a lot of the
changes that Marvel was making were not
very well received
what Marvel did is they followed up and
said okay fine we'll go back to basics
they were gonna release a story called
Marvel legacy what legacy is a one-shot
and all its gonna do is just give us all
the mantles of the characters who have
existed over the years
Avengers like 1 million or 1 billion or
10,000 BC or whatever it is I don't
remember the exact number but it's
basically gonna tell us there's been a
long line of these different iterations
of Heroes marvel marvel generations
these are basically just fill-in comics
there's one shots they don't really
pertain to anything in particular at
least they don't seem to instead it's
just kind of stories that give us the
newer characters juxtaposed to the
classic characters but the idea here is
that like most of the generations
stories the newer modern characters in
this case all-new all-different
Wolverine x-23 is suddenly just thrown
into the past with classic Wolverine now
to catch up people who were a little new
here who are basically stumbling across
this looking to get into Marvel for the
first time
x-23 Laura Kinney is basically a clone
of Wolverine now originally it was
supposed to be a clone of Wolverine down
to the T which is to say a male clone a
guy walking around looking just like
Wolverine and this was basically done by
this sort of rebooted version of Weapon
X you know I guess really created by a
guy named Zander rice or at least not
really created by him but for the most
part the project's being run by him but
the idea is that you know this newer
version of Weapon X under under Zander
Rice look to clone Wolverine and
basically sent him on a series of
missions to the highest bidder whoever
it was that paid the most money would
have Wolverine carry out that mission
again it's a little bit of a change here
with regards to her character but on the
whole as she's been written over the
years and as she's been depicted whether
it was in the
x-men evolution animated series or it
was in the actual comic itself she's
basically faster than Wolverine she's a
little more fluid in her movements than
Wolverine is were asked classic
Wolverines just like this guy who really
knows how to fight well and he knows all
different kinds of martial arts but he's
really more of just like a slash he just
goes in there and just starts slashing
away at things and that's really about
it but the fact remains here when it
comes to this particular story Wolverine
has fought the hand on a multitude of
occasions but that's why I say this
particular story goes back to 1984 and
the reason why is because of the x-23
showing up you know in helping a classic
Wolverine fight alongside the hand and
then basically defeat the hand allowing
one of them to leave so they could
basically trace you know where this
guy's going to and find this girl
Emiko the reason why this is important
is because amigo made her appearance
after the events of secret Wars the
original seeker wars back in 1984 now
and involve this really weird story in
uncanny x-men 181 I think it was the
young and the dragon I'm not 100% sure
what it was exactly what the title was
but it was basically this idea that like
this dragon essentially followed you
know the I guess you know come with the
x-men back to earth after the events of
secret wars and went on this giant
rampage and a killed appearance of Miko
and so in response
Logan basically adopted her as her own
the issue is that he couldn't really
take care of her and so what he ended up
doing was giving her to his love
interest at the time a girl named Mariko
now what this story does is it fits in
those two places and it actually goes
back and changes those things a bit for
the most part it was basically believed
that the idea was that with Wolverine
being part of the x-men he just couldn't
take care of a Miko he could not be an
x-man and a parent at the at the same
time it just there was no room for that
he either had to devote us but devote
his time to one or devote his time to
the other now in truth he could have
done both but he would have done a
shoddy job at both of them and so the
result was that he chose to give up
Emiko and go back just go back to his
life of being an x-man now the way the
story was written back in 1984 in 1985
because Chris Claremont was writing the
x-men at the time it wasn't just like a
throwaway thing Chris Claremont was
always about character development
that's the only thing that matter was
developing characters and so what he
ended up doing was basically introducing
this character as the possibility of
Wolverine
having a daughter and then hand her over
to Mariko and then leave it and then
just wait and see how fans respond and
if fans respond positively then bringing
up bringing me go back for a couple more
issues and then you know have her go
away again and if fans respond to that
then bring her back again and then
eventually you begin the process of this
slow gradual build building this
character up introducing this character
and then in turn giving her a larger
role within the x-men universe is the
same thing that Marvel did with X 23 X
23 had her origin story she was on the
scene but she didn't replace Wolverine
right off the bat and said you got this
slow build where she came to terms with
her father she fought Wolverine on a
couple of occasions and beat the crap
out of him the first time they fought it
was pretty cool
but it's an interesting scenario because
Claremont was all about character
development and it's interesting because
if he go and read his stories you know
when he watches interviews his argument
is basically anybody can make a story
where heroes fight each other that's not
hard what's hard is creating characters
that people care about that they can
relate to that's the difficult thing and
so again once they get back into this
Hana facility having followed this guy
they're suddenly met by a surprise
grenade and then of course some guy
shows up and basically says you know
says hey look we as the hand were duped
we were paid to kidnap this girl
we were not paid for what he's asking
now now when it comes to the hand in
Marvel Comics they are basically
available to the highest bidder but woe
betide the poor soul who betrays the
hand and that's the way it works you
didn't go to them you can go to this
mystical Japanese ninja Society and you
can say hey look I want to hire your
services and they'll charge you a lot of
money but if you can pay it then they'll
do whatever you want to that's what
makes the hand so dangerous the hand are
virtually untraceable and they're
everywhere I mean they're all over the
place they're in government's they're in
businesses they're in regular society
half the time you could walk by a member
of the hand and never know it
they are that clandestine and if the
hand are basically paid to commit an act
they'll do whatever it is they have to
do in order to commit that act whether
it's eliminating you know corporate
rivals whether it's eliminating
politicians whatever the case may be if
they are tasked with a goal they will
take it out and what makes them so
dangerous is no one knows how it
happened some senators sitting in his
office somewhere and then there's a
scuffle and then somebody walks
the senator is dead there's no
indication anybody was ever there the
windows are still locked the vents
aren't open nobody knows how it was the
senator died they're just gone and it's
one of those weird situations it's kind
of cool and it's really intriguing with
regards to the hand well that's why you
don't see them too often because they're
kind of this MacGuffin you know kind of
this well you know they'll lindo solve
all the world's problems you know and
it's kind of a funny situation but
ultimately they end up tracking down
where it is a Miko's being held which of
course is at an airport in Tokyo when
they arrived there we end up finding out
the person who engineered all of this is
Sabretooth now as far as I'm aware and
I'm gonna go out on a limb here as far
as I'm aware x-23 and Sabretooth
have never really had like a true
one-on-one fight they've scuffled a few
times before I believe they actually
encountered and scuffle during the
events of Wolverines but I do not
believe they've had like a true
one-on-one battle and when I say like a
true of one-on-one battle I'm talking
about like the ferocity of the battles
between like classic Wolverine and
Sabretooth because their fights were
legendary man those are stuff of legend
if you look at the fights between
Sabretooth and Wolverine they are
absolutely amazing in terms of the two
of them tearing each other apart but the
general gist of this idea is that both
x-23 and classic Wolverine of course
board the board the plane only to
realize that Sabretooth was the one who
had basically kidnapped
Emiko now of course this leads directly
to x-23 facing off against Sabretooth
and the fight here is kind of
interesting for the most part I'm gonna
go out on a limb and say that I do not
believe under any normal circumstance
that x-23 would actually defeat quite
like classic Sabretooth this version of
Sabretooth back from the 1980s if it was
the more modern version probably but
with regards to like this classic
version most likely not because the way
he was written back then is he was
devoid of any morality whatsoever he was
just this cruel sadistic thing who was
more like an animal than an actual
person and would basically tear apart
anybody that he would come across now
the other half of this is that with x-23
she is extremely fast and one of the
only real reasons why she was able to
take out classical of rain is because of
the fact that she's not as heavy as he
is due to the fact that she does not
have adamantium laced to her bones
she has adamantium laced to her claws
but she does
not have an adamantium skeleton and so
because of this it actually weighs down
Wolverine now his body somewhat adapted
to cope with that but you're literally
talking about just this giant force just
swinging at things whereas with x-23
she's fluid she's quick she's fast
you know all those little things that go
into her training as a prodigious black
ops agent so again it's sort of an
interesting scenario I'm kind of curious
who do you guys think would actually win
and like a brutal no-holds-barred the
landscapes empty they're fighting out in
the middle of the desert who do you
think would win between like x-23 and
classic Sabretooth because again I kind
of think it's classic Sabretooth here
but the overall gist is that x-23 knows
who Sabretooth is right like she's been
around the process long enough to know I
mean again you know they they had been
side by side and Wolverines along side
like mystique and so on and so forth
so she knows what Sabretooth is about
but again as far as I'm aware she never
encountered classic Sabretooth so she
doesn't really know exactly how hardcore
Sabretooth can be now of course with her
offering somewhat of a distraction
ultimately this results in you know
Logan our gues classic Wolverine showing
up and then just kind of like you know
attacking attacking Sabretooth now of
course x-23 uses this as a momentary
distraction to basically incapacitate
him again remember he has a healing
factor so being stabbed through the
throat is not gonna kill him you know
it'll just it'll send him running in
that I'm in Chile he'll heal and he'll
come back and do whatever it is that he
does next but with regards to him
transferring amico over to Mariko this
again basically kind of wraps back
around to the idea of what Chris
Claremont did that that Wolverine
basically takes as this daughter you
know so to speak and says okay look
Mariko you have to watch over her I
don't have the ability to do this now
the biggest reason and one of the
coolest things about this is this leads
to a direct conflict between x-23 and
classic will rain now on the surface it
would be easy to look at this and just
say okay well is the old classic
Wolverine
you know he's like I can't be an x-man
and take care of a daughter at the same
time and x-23 is like yes you can but
remember x-23
is basically the daughter of Logan is as
close as he ever got to having a
biological daughter you know about
having a biological child of his own
outside of bacon bacon of course was a
whole nother kettle of beans when it
came to like you know a son's hatred for
his dad
but the idea is that with x-23 she looks
at this scenario and actually reflects
on her own life because remember it
wasn't until she showed up at the Xavier
Institute that Wolverine even knew she
existed
I mean she was basically taken from some
DNA samples left behind when classic
Wolverine originally escaped the Weapon
X project she was basically grown in
isolation or I guess raised in isolation
after having been born she was trained
to be a prejudice assassin in isolation
she went on these black ops missions in
isolation she never really experienced
the outside world beyond whatever
mission she was assigned at the time I
mean she met like her aunt you know when
her cousin different things like that
but that was about it I mean she didn't
go out and meet teams of people and so
on and so forth it wasn't until she till
the basically you know Xander rice was
killed the entire facility was burned
down she accidentally ended up killing
her mother and that she basically took
off into the world that she began to
explore and see what was out there but
one of the first people she came across
was classic Wolverine but even then even
encountering her his stance was hey look
I mean I guess you're like a clone of me
but you're not really a daughter and he
never really treats her like a daughter
now this is not because he does a viewer
that way it's because Wolverine never
really treats anybody like a child I
mean he does to it agree with like Kitty
Pryde but that's about the extent of it
you know Kitty Pryde was more like he
was more like a father figure to her
because that's how his character was
written at the time and because it was
so intrinsic because they had like a
comic together you know Wolverine and
Kitty Pryde because they had a story
together you know it was one of those
lasting you know father-daughter type
relationships that Marvel just kind of
kept going forever after a while they
would you know go off on their own
adventures but it was always an
undercurrent it was always the idea of
hey look like I am a father figure for
you you know you are like a daughter to
me
you know I view you that way we confide
in each other about all our problems and
different things like that 4x 23 she
never got that treatment she shows up
well rain just like who in the world are
you you know eventually he figures out
what's going on with her she joins
x-force she fights alongside Wolverine
for a little while
tries to figure out her place in the
x-men and that's really about it she
never really had a proper upbringing and
so in her mind where Wolverine is in
this position where he has the ability
to relate to this daughter that he has
and he's basically adopted where he has
the ability to relate to amico and
sted decides to like turn tail and run
back to the x-men she calls him
basically a coward and says like it's
easier for you to just run away and be
an x-man it's easier for you to just run
away from all your problems pretend like
she doesn't exist then it is for you to
actually be a father and it's a great
bonding moment because she misses
classic wolf remember he died like he's
dead you know he ended up being encased
in adamantium and that was the end of it
you know she never really had a chance
to actually bond with him the way that a
daughter would bond with her father and
so this presents a circumstance at least
for her to say goodbye one last time but
for her to also pass on this little bit
of a story and say go spend time with
your daughter if you're not gonna do it
for yourself at least do it for me
because I'd like to have some peace and
knowing there's at least somebody out
there that you cared about but it's also
a little bit of living vicariously
through a Mika because if x-23 can go
forward believing that classic Wolverine
actually took care of this girl the way
he was supposed to then any Neil Laura's
mine he's taking care of her so it's
really kind of a cool you know a little
bit of a moment between these characters
and it's interesting to me and that's
one of the reasons why I like it is
because x-23 in classic Wolverine have
this father/daughter dynamic but it's
like in a strange daughter in a strange
father they know who the other is but
they're like two ships passing in the
night they say hey what's up and then
that's it that's really all there is to
it and so again it's kind of a cool
scenario and it's one of mine one of the
reasons why I think this is definitely
one of the better Marvel generation
stories but I'm curious let me know what
you guys think down in the comments you
guys like you guys like this you guys
are just like don't care I'm kind of
curious what you all think but anyway if
you guys are new here to comments
explain and make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]